stay on your own path you're on the
right path my path find your own path
you must find your own path
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can find your path
and as always as people are talking if
they take something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put posts around
it so other people can be inspired as
well enjoy I had a yoga teacher who said
to me always stay on your own yoga mat
because sometimes if you're in headstand
and you're too busy looking at the
person the other mat you could literally
break your neck I feel like that's a
really good metaphor for life to stay on
your own path do what's right for you
can't compare your insides of somebody
else's outsides because you never know
what's going on for somebody else really
every pursuit no matter how glamorous it
may seem no matter how exciting you are
it feels to you no matter how much you
feel like you were born to do it comes
with a sandwich and so the question is
not what do I love the question is what
do I love so much that I don't mind
eating the sandwich that comes along
with that thing so for me in my life
writing is the thing that I love and the
sandwich was the 7 years that I was not
getting published and that I was coming
home from my job as a diner waitress as
a bartender as an au pair as a via
worked in flea market as a cook and I
was coming home tired and smelling like
other people's french fries and sitting
down and doing my real job which was to
write and then to go to the mailbox the
next day and get another rejection
letter and then say do I still wanna do
this because I know and I did still want
to do it and now even as somebody who
makes their living as a writer there's
no end to the sandwiches it's like oh
hello horrible review in prominent
newspaper that's your sandwich today was
you still want to do this work yeah yeah
I still do still worth it like Hello
awful comment on social media from
somebody who thinks you're a pile of
yeah you know I just have like chosen
every possible way that they can just
cannot get it out of their system fast
enough much disregard they have for your
entire life yes still want to do this
thing yeah I still want to do it you
know so that's the question because it's
the first time you encounter the
sandwich you're like well this this
isn't worth it then that's not the thing
you're supposed to be doing yes and
there are plenty of things in life that
that I have run into a sandwich and I've
been like so not worth it so not worth
it like this is now I don't want to do
this like whatever the bed alleged
benefits of this thing might be no downs
with no cycle no you know like I know
it's probably really good for me but I
feel like throwing up right now make you
hard about you'll not be seeing me here
again you know like I'm and I love my
sister's at soul cycle I just don't like
feeling like I'm to throw up when I
exercise so it's not for me you know and
and so that's the question so if you go
into this thing thinking if I follow my
bliss and I live my dream and I stand in
my truth and everything will be great it
doesn't mean everything will be great
it just means at the end of the day when
you check in with yourself and you go in
the end on the balance is this still
better than not doing it and the answer
is still yeah this thing's still better
than not doing it and you're on the
right path my whole family is funny I
have a really funny funny
samih like weird the whole family can
tell jokes and there's a dozens and all
that so we're always really funny around
the house when I realized what I want to
be a comedian with Richard Pryor who was
like oh that's that's what I wanted
1976 I think it was a album he put out
called that [ __ ] crazy and I remember
just sitting and listening to it over
and over and over and over and over and
over and that was kind of where it
started that's where I realized when I
was what I want to do my first gig out
of college was on Wall Street on the New
York Stock Exchange and this is pre
everything this is like just at a
college twenty-one years old and I knew
one of my drive I wanted to be really
successful but not just because I get
shoes I knew I wanted to make money
because I wanted to make a difference I
wanted to be able to take care of my
family I wanted to be able to contribute
to causes that I believe in and so I
knew in order to do that in my own mind
I was like well I want to make a lot of
money and you make this stuff happen but
when I was on Wall Street even though so
many people that I worked with multi
multimillionaires I mean the money was
ridiculous while they were financially
rich they were spiritually bankrupt and
I felt like there was a part of me that
was dying inside and I said this is not
my path I don't know what my path is but
I need to leave this because I feel sick
and so I think many people feel like
that you can find yourself and job and
job and job and you want to do a really
you want to do great work in the world
you're giving it your best
some little voice inside and saying this
isn't me this isn't me and I kept having
that voice until finally I left the
corporate world and started my own
business I think it's important for
people to understand that any time you
step out of what's normal and society
you're going to have criticism so many
people follow the traditional plan with
no thought whatsoever as to what they
really want to do in life you know they
go to school they go to high school they
go to college they can't agreed to get
married they have kids then they
wake up with 40 years old wondering what
just happened and where did my life go
and when I think about those things I
think about how much criticism we got
when we started our first company we're
only 19 years old to do all the things
that you're supposed to do in society
you know all the people that used to
tell us you guys waste your time you
need to get a degree you need to get a
real job you need to quit you know waste
your time with this hobby and those are
the same people now that you know
they're telling on top of a job we did
and how proud we are and I think about
that a lot and I think people don't
realize that same criticism that they
get for doing anything outside of what's
considered normal
that goes for anybody that tries
anything outside of what's normal and I
think people need to realize that people
are going to talk they're going to
criticize but what's more important
what's more important is that you do
what it is you think you need to do
instead of changing your path for
everybody else was happiness because the
reality is the people who judge you
aren't doing anything different are the
same people who can't do it themselves
and I feel like so many people get so
wrapped up into what other people think
that they ruin their entire lives living
a life that they don't even want live
everybody's got to find their own path
and you have to realize it when you get
on that path you're stopped you're going
to make mistakes you're gonna have that
like really bad but as long as you're
willing to learn and you're willing to
take those as lessons about and you're
smart enough to not make the same
mistakes over and over and over again
there's really nothing that you can't do
a little more about me once you write
something and rap instead of spitting on
everybody and I wrote it and everybody
liked it and I started doing it more and
then I finally won a contest first thing
I've ever won of my life the thing I
once fell on my graduation day so I
chose to open up for EPMD and climbing
all those people at Kemper Arena in
Kansas City Missouri rather than walk
across the stage right up the street
while all my partners were graduating
and that's when I knew what I was gonna
do for the rest of my life you know your
graduation day you get your diploma and
you choose something else and then you
end up doing what you do which you
planned on doing and you're young and
it's not written in blood that you're
going to make it and you you move from
house to house because you run away from
home at 17 you move from place to place
with family members and friends and
everything trying to do music and then
you end up doing it then you end up on
the Forbes list and working with all the
people that inspired you like Ice Cube
and the doors and Roger Troutman and you
know it's wonderful you know and so that
was the most monumental to me while
traditional paths may seem harder to
find that also means that you may lune
learn sooner than most generations the
hard lesson that you must always make
the path to yourself there is no secret
society out there that will tap you on
the shoulder one night and show you the
way because the true secret is your life
will not be defined by the society that
we have left you to paraphrase Robert
bolt society has no more idea of
you are than you do because ultimately
it has only your brains to think with
every generation must define itself and
so make the world that suits itself so
if you must find your own path and we
have left you no easy path then decide
now to choose the hard path that leads
to the life and the world that you want
and I know about your school on another
lady that I would like you to tell us
about who inspired you and encourage you
to do your music can you tell us a bit
behind well as Lena McGlynn like my
second mother and I she's a pastor and
everything my teeth my music teacher in
high school in high school my freshman
year I was a star Don King with
basketball team's name with my high
school and but I happened to have a
music class at that point in time I
wasn't and I think I was about 16 17 I
was not I was not interested in music I
was really trying to be the next Michael
Jordan of course and she told me that I
was saying you know I would be the next
50 wonder or superstar Michael Jackson
or something like that not and I laughed
at her like she was crazy you know I was
I couldn't see it and everything I am
today she could see it my mother could
see it and she would tell me that I was
going to be where I'm at today and even
farther so and it just had just happened
I put me in a talent show and I did the
talent show and the girls were screaming
and everything and I was like man I I
don't get this kind of love on the court
you know and of course I'm going to
choose that over basketball and I did
and I've been doing it ever since
so what would you would you say that was
your big break or third stage a little
further down the line that was
significant breakthrough music I would
say my big break is that point in time I
learned that Stevie Wonder uh riff I was
one of the steps because I felt like man
if I learned that I could learn anything
I was going pretty fast but as far as
crowd wise and what nailed it I would
say my first talent show
pretty much what bit me in a way like
Peter Parker got bit by the spider and
became spider-man you know that was that
was the bike for me you know when we
were women and everybody was showing me
so much love at the talent show and I
want and I was like wow it was
overwhelming when did you know that you
wanted to be a comedian Rick we really
got her a little older when I was young
that was in high school and I knew I
wasn't going to college because I barely
got out of high school that's that
better find something right quick
laughter what am I good at you know how
I was making people laugh and I was like
wow y'all laughing it's like it's funny
you remind me Eddie Murphy so I said let
me try this out and a host my talent
show in high school and I got my first
laughs and I got an epiphany and I was
like I'm gonna do this no cuz it's fun
and I'm already you know so that's what
I found out I hosted my first talent
show hosted of talent show in high
school and I said that's what I want to
do the alarm clock would go off very
early every single morning I'd wake up I
checked my phone immediately for any
emails that had come in and then it'd be
the hour shave dress in my full suit and
jump in a car and that car to me
represented my first kind of drudgery
task for the day it made me feel trapped
because I'd done all the right things I
had gone to college I had been an
officer in the army 14 years I've gone
to corporate finance I'd worked with
John Hancock I done commercial real
estate I had done all the right things
and now here I was stuck on this hamster
wheel going nowhere inspiring nobody
especially not myself and just feeling
like I was trapped in
world that I had created and it was a
stinking pit in my stomach and I just
was wondering why why have I not fowl am
looking for when I've done everything
that I was told I was supposed to do
Here I am years later on this team
hamster wheels and I like I even further
behind where I thought I was five years
ago and the stinky mundane feeling would
just not go away it was ever-present
with me and I just wanted freedom and I
just wanted freedom I just wanted to do
work that I was inspired by and I just
wanted to import and inspired other
[Music]
you
so there I was stuck in traffic again
but at least I had my podcast or so I
thought
then before I knew it who my last
podcast had ended and I scroll through
my ipod and there was nothing left and I
thought to myself man I just did here
another 45 minutes in traffic with
nothing but the radio I was devastated
but at that moment at that devastation
moment that is truly when my aha moment
happened that's not a light bulb went
off a headlight there's not a
seven-day-a-week
podcast there should be a podcast that
comes out every single day of the week
that interviews inspiring a successful
entrepreneur and that's when I have my
light bulb well rested there should be
someone that creates it why not me
I know all these great entrepreneurs who
are hosts of their own shows I could be
just like them I can do that so I had
all of these thoughts swirling in my
head am I going to fail am I going to
look like a fool front of my friends and
family up to this point and only see me
as a success and these were real fear I
used to wake up sweating in the middle
of the night saying what am i doing this
is insane and the only way that I was
here to go back to sleep would by
convincing myself that when I woke up in
the morning I was going to give it all
up and go crawling back to my job
but luckily for me I would wake up in
the morning someone be shining and I
think you know what I'm going to give it
one more day one more day I'm going to
sit down I'm going to learn what it
takes to upload a media file I'm going
to learn how to create great audio on
the world it takes to be an interviewer
a host of a show in every single day I
would get shot down I would struggle I
would come up against another wall that
would knock me down but I kept getting
up I kept taking one step forward for
every half step taking back and slowly
but surely I saw myself turning into a
podcaster ready for my very own eye and
it was a slow process that did come and
I was able to continue to move forward
until the watch entrenar sire on
September 22nd because at that point
there was no turning back
Fire Nation look what we created look at
the inspiration we spread throughout
this world if
yeah seven days a week interviewing the
most inspiring a successful autumn
viewers in the world Jeff Gould and Guy
Kawasaki embarrassed Gary Vaynerchuk we
are listened to in over 145 countries
millions and millions of unique
downloads fire nations look at what we
created look at what we've done and
we've just started thank you guys so
much for watching I love to know what
did you think what Clips has the biggest
impact on you that you're going to
immediately apply to your life or your
business also curious about how you
found your path or any struggles that
you are finding along the journey of
finding your path
leave it in the comments below and I'm
super curious to figure out what you
guys have on your mind finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Kaylee and
Bradley thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word and for
taking that awesome picture with your
belief tattoo I love it thank you so
much for sharing that as well
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon